Speaker 1: Welcome to the show. I am coming
to you today from very sunny and extremely hot
Las Vegas, Nevada. I will tell everybody a little
bit later on in the week what I am up to here.
Apologies in advance if the show doesn't sound or
look exactly the way it normally does. We're doing
the best we can with the equipment we have, but
I think it will be pretty good. I want to start
today by talking about the difference between an
economic reality and a political reality. What
do I mean by that? If the job situation is good
according to economic measures, but voters don't
know it or they don't think it's good, then the
political reality of the jobs market is still bad,
even if the jobs numbers are good, and that's
exactly what we have going on right now. You know,
there's this phrase, it's the economy stupid.
I don't remember if it was a Clinton campaign
advisor, James Carville, that came up with that
or who it was. But it's the economy, stupid. The
economy is what matters. The economy ultimately
is what determines whether voters say, Yeah,
give me more of the same if the economy is good or
it's time for a change if the economy's bad. Well,
one of the main measures that we have of how the
economy is doing is a sort of two-fold measure,
which is the monthly jobs report, and it gives
us two elements of data. One of those is the
unemployment rate. The other is the number of
jobs created in March. The numbers were very
good and they were very good. Again, the
numbers have been good for several months
now under Joe Biden's presidency. Now, to what
degree Joe Biden is responsible for the numbers?
It's always a question. We ask that under every
president fair question to ask, but to the extent
that people vote based on how the economy is
doing, this is happening. While Joe Biden is
president three point six percent unemployment
rate as of March, that is considered essentially
full employment in the United States. Four hundred
and thirty one thousand jobs created in March, a
very healthy number of new jobs. So this should be
great for Joe Biden's not so good approval rating,
right? I mean, great jobs numbers should help
Joe Biden, except there is new polling that shows
voters think unemployment is high. Now,
some voters may think unemployment is high
because there are other measures they are
looking at, like inflation gas prices. And
maybe they're confused or assuming that the job
market must also be bad. But also, there's been
a deliberate effort by Republicans to tell people
the employment situation is bad, even though it's
actually pretty good. So let's be very specific.
People were polled by Navigator research. This
did not get a lot of attention. This happened last
month. And what the Navigator research poll showed
was that 37 percent of the public thinks that
there has been a job loss in the last year. Now.
One thing would be there have been massive jobs
gains, but some people think there only have been
little jobs gains that would be wrong. But it's
at least closer to reality. More than a third,
nearly 40 percent of this country thinks that
over the last year we have lost jobs. OK. Only
28 percent believe that over the last year
we have gained jobs. It's more a particularly
Partizan. Republicans are extra likely
to think that jobs have been lost.
Tons of jobs have been gained. Now we can
still talk about wages. We can talk about
the quality of jobs we can tell you. A lot of
these jobs don't provide health care, of course.
Of course, we can say all of those things, but
there have been massive jobs gains over the last
year. There have been there has been a significant
reduction in the unemployment rate since Joe Biden
took office. Remember when Biden was sworn
in, the unemployment rate was 6.4 percent.
It's now 3.6 percent. It hasn't quite been
halved, but pretty damn close. And this is all.
This is two things. This is partially. People
just don't know what's going on. Partially,
people might be saying, well, if inflation is
so high, then probably the job market is bad.
But Republicans have actually been
saying the job situation is terrible.
We played one clip on yesterday's show.
Representative Republican Representative
Republican Congresswoman Lisa McClain. We
played some clips of her speaking at the
Trump rally in Michigan, and she said unemployment
is at a 40 year high. Remember this clip
Speaker 2: we want from an
economy that was booming
to a shambles? What we have now is a shambles
is a complete mess. Unemployment, 40 year high
labor shortage. We can't find goods
Speaker 1: at the store. So of course,
the truth is that unemployment is
extremely low and it is significantly
lower than it was when Donald Trump left
office. So at the end of of of the day,
this is about two things one does Joe Biden need
accomplishments? Yes. I mean, listen. Trump lost
in 2020. He barely lost, but part of the reason
he lost was he lacked accomplishments. He said
he would do a wall and he didn't. He said he
would replace Obamacare with something beautiful,
and he didn't. He said he would beat COVID and he
didn't, you know, he didn't have accomplishments.
So do you need accomplishments? It helps
to have them. You can just claim them,
but it helps to actually have accomplishments.
But if the voters don't know. That the reality
is the reality there are going to vote for someone
else, and so I don't know who to blame for this.
But the jobs market is good, and many Republicans
think jobs have been lost and nearly 40 percent of
Americans think jobs have been lost. Something has
to be done in order for this to lead to anything
other than democratic disaster. In November of
2022. Now just what? Six and a half months away?
I don't exactly know what the solution is,
but these are basic facts, basic facts.